foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome to Piers Morgan I'm censored
coming up on tonight's program sunak is
back if at first you don't succeed but
can Rishi right the wrongs unite the
Tory party and save the country he flew
in but his leadership campaign failed to
take off is this Boris Johnson's final
bumpy Landing and heavy is the head that
rides the crown Netflix it drama branded
sadistic and wicked for recreating
Princess Diana's Final hours have they
gone too far
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Nadine Doris and Emily
Sheffield
United sitting at the Pierce for a
couple of days alongside Emily Sheffield
please enjoy your sunshine in La Nadine
and I have got this one what a weekend
it's been the grown-ups are finally back
in charge playtime is over and not a
moment too soon the nation can finally
been that Valium prescription now that
it is Rishi sunak who will become the
UK's 57th prime minister
what do we need from a PM well someone
who isn't a narcissistic nightmare would
be a good start but the big priority
right now is for a leader to sort out
our nation's finances and reassure
Global markets that Britain can pay its
bills
which he understands in life you can't
get something for nothing at a time when
a country is crying out for fiscal
responsibility our new prime minister is
already proving that he is the
embodiment of that as Chancellor and in
running for the leader this summer he
showed he was willing to tell us the
hard truths we all have to swallow in
addition his prophetic warnings about
what would occur if Liz truss took power
flaunting her magic money tree came to
pass with horrendous consequences for us
all
whereas Boris seem to struggle telling
the truth about goings-on in the past
Rishi will tell you he says what is
going to happen in the future for the
last year the Tories have focused on
their own Psycho Drama as good as Rishi
sunak may be our problems remain huge
can he unify a party that has spent more
time fighting each other than the
opposition
can he get us through a prolonged
recession delivering compassionate
conservatism amongst brutal cuts it's
now time for some stability it's time
for Rishi it's time for our politicians
to focus on you not themselves
it is clearly now the will of the
Parliamentary conservative party that
there should be a new leader
interest rates go on please let Let's
cross on I don't accept those points his
trust is elected as the leader of the
conservative Union as part
I'm not going to cut the additional
rates of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together how
many people voted for your plan
[Music]
what do you mean by that Mr Speaker I'm
genuinely unclear but it is clear that
parts of our mini budget went further
and faster the markets were expecting uh
I am a fighter and not a quitter I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected Rishi sunak is therefore
elected as leaders
[Applause]
joining us in the studio this evening
political sketchwriter quentinlet let's
talk TV contributor Ava Santina and the
daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire now we've just watched that
little video and I can tell you that
most of us sitting around this table and
much of you watching probably feel like
you've had whiplash for the last few
months but Nadine
Nadine has had a ringside seat to all
the craziness not just of the last few
days but of the last many months Nadine
I first want to take you back because I
think what's foremost in all our minds
is is
what the hell happened the last three
days now I know from our chats backstage
that you were one of the first people to
ring Boris on Thursday after Liz truss
resigned and you had some resignations
about him coming back into the fight can
you can you just talk us through that
first call with him
so um he didn't have reservations but I
think there were a very small group
around him
um people who were concerned about him
and Carrie and the children and the
family and who we had our reservations
about whether it was the right thing to
do
we felt so soon after half an hour was
this just a few of you that are yeah I'm
very very are you able to talk to us
about me those few are but you were one
of the first on the phone too yeah yeah
absolutely and he's on the sun lounger
at this point he was on the Sundown
church I didn't ask but he was yeah no
it was it was a very fast moving
situation situation it was we didn't
expect it to happen as quickly as it did
and um it was a bit of a shock that 1 30
announcement I think it was for them Liz
that she was standing down so things
moved very fast and he was he was up for
it he got on the flight home and he was
ready to go so what when it given that
you had some reservations when he said
no Nadine I want to do this what were
his reasons to you
so
you know we're facing we are in a very
difficult situation at the moment the
one thing we do know about Boris is he
is a winner and it's less than three
years ago he won an ATC majority
in a generation I think he feels that
their party is in a factional and
perilous State and that it needed
someone who those those MPS in the red
wall seats could see would win their
seats and keep them their their seats in
the future and he could bring the party
together and who had the ability you
know he has a unique mandate he was the
person who was elected by the people
well actually Emily you might say that
you know but there are people in Mad
wall seats like red car and other places
who have voted labor all of their lives
and they would rather have their
toenails removed one by one without an
aesthetic before they would say they
voted conservative what they say is we
voted for Boris well
were absolutely horrified I would take
that back to you in as much as when I
was Secretary of State in dcms I went
around the northeast of England and
spoke to a lot of people and there is a
very definite positive Boris vibe in
those areas you know the MP for Grimsby
Leah Nikki will tell you he's he's loved
in her constituency and I think he felt
that in order to keep those red wool
seats that it was his duty and his
responsibility as the only MP in the
conservative party to have a mandate to
lead the conservative
after 57 Tory ministers resigned from
his government and cabinet when you were
having those initial discussions with
him and those close around him did this
come up because would he be the the one
that was able to unify unify his MPS
around him because you can't go oven
unless you do have the backing of your
MPS so that's a much bigger question
actually led into a different discussion
and that discussion was you know you
could do this but Rishi and Penny
mordant had to agree that the party
needed to unify and that as he was the
person who would only think they would
go behind him because he was the only
person who actually has a as a mandate
from the public and a general election
is the last thing the conservative party
needs at the moment and it's pretty
obvious and I think we're seeing it
today already that if we put another
leader who didn't have a mandate from
the public to lead the conservative
party and to become the third prime
minister in 50 something days then then
we're going to come back because I I
think there's lots more to talk about
what happened this weekend and and
obviously you did have a very a lot of
insight you're on the phone to Boris a
lot of the time but Kevin is that right
about he's the only one who had a
mandate yeah he won in 2019 in brexit
was his trump card he never delivered it
the way he promised it uh he was up
against Jeremy corbyn but nevertheless
he did win and he won a very healthy
majority for the conservative party this
trust didn't wish he sooner didn't
that's gone now and I I agree with
Nadine uh the case for a general
election now I think is overwhelming now
constitutionally parliamentary democracy
doesn't mean there will be one but I
think if the new prime minister Rishi
sunak wants any Authority legitimacy
credibility they have to win a mandate
and that is why that's the main reason
why Boris decided to stand I believe was
because he does have that unique
political Monday that nobody else in the
conservative party has it's undeniable
you know
he's gone though I think there was a
Boris Johnson uh 2019. he lost the
support of the party
continues it's only just over a year ago
that we won the Hartlepool by-election
with the landslide but of course since
then you've had party gay everything
else that came along with it and you saw
what happened in Tiverton
in North Shropshire in Wakefield in the
red wall all those by-elections were
lost heavily
you you you you're a sketchwriter for
the times they came out strongly for
Rishi sunak why why do you think Boris
didn't manage to re-gather the support
of his party I mean there were plenty of
people who probably in the Tory party
had their head in their hands
when you spend time at Westminster on
our day like this you realize what a
bunch of wrigglers and dirty-eyed
lizards they all are and they are
looking not just at the future of their
seats and you know that's a justifiable
thing they're party politicians they're
also thinking about their personal
Ambitions who can give me a job you know
who's who's up and who's down that is
the most driving uh sort of melodrama at
Westminster on a day like this so it's a
very peculiar place the Palace of
Westminster because it's this just this
Crucible of Ambitions and uh there's a
lot of that going on and a lot of the
people who perhaps didn't want Boris to
come back this time uh in the among the
MPS were people that he had not given
jobs to or who might not have got jobs
it isn't sure there aren't you know some
people who were really worried about
party games
got a lot of things right he got Ukraine
right he got the vaccines right but
there is no denying at the time when his
government when his government Emily
there were problems can I just get a
word in Rishi was also working in the
same buildings what Boris Johnson knew
about partygate wishing you Rishi was
fined as well they were working in the
same buildings day and night with the
same people breathing the same air doing
exactly the same thing why do you think
Boris is more guilty a party gate than
Russia
and the polls were that he was minus 51
at the time he was deeply unpopular he
was he was
sister I do want I do because I think we
could argue this out for hours and I
think we should concentrate on what's
happened this weekend a bit and I just
want to take you back he met up with
um he met up with Rishi sunak and Penny
mordant and obviously those meetings
didn't go to plan are you able to just
because I'm sure you were talking to him
what was the
what was his pitch to them I guess when
he went in there about why the old gang
should reform because that's what we
heard that was what he was saying to
them let's let's get this back together
what do you think he said to Rishi or
was hoping to say to Rishi that would
make Rishi feel that they could work
together cohesively so um just to
correction on something you said a
moment ago you said that Boris didn't
get the support I think we need to put
this onto bed he had a hundred and two
signatures the support was there for him
to go on the ballot today it was his
decision not to as a result of those
conversations and it brings me back that
Rishi had far more MPS at that point no
that all he all bikers needed to get
quite a large number all Boris needed to
get onto the ballot was the 100
signatures which he had and we know as
the polling is very clearly shown
the vote I mean after all this year came
second to Liz truss Boris would very
easily have one with the members but
it's not just about winning with a
membership but George Osborne actually
in fact pointed out on Sunday when was
that if you can't command your party and
have the confidence of your MPS you are
not going to stay prime minister for
very long isn't that part of the reason
he pulled out he knew he couldn't
command his party anymore well
I think that Unity as we has been spoken
a lot about today and that was
incredibly important it is incredibly
important you know Unity stability
growth all those things that matter
moving forward and Boris went into those
meetings with Rishi and Penny hoping
that they could reach an agreement that
would unify the party on the basis that
he was the only MP with a mandate from
the public at The Ballot Box to be prime
minister it's a very important point
it's one that's going to come back to
haunters day after day after day you
know if we add up the nominations Penny
mordant claims Boris Johnson claims
because she Sue not claims yeah but
there's more there are more nominations
than there are Tory MPS they can't all
be telling the truth I've actually kept
that's not true at all
[Music]
180. then we get the three seven in
there's about 350. you're talking about
the different stages of the process as
you know
does anyone here does anyone here think
Rishi do you Ava do you think rishi's
the man do you think he's the right man
for the job at the moment well I mean
where she said something interesting
today in his speech which was he was he
would bring honesty and integrity to the
role which I think we haven't seen in a
couple of years and we also know that
you know the entire type the entire
Administration that Boris Johnson would
want to conduct over the next couple of
months would be marred by this
privilegious committee that is going to
be coming up and we're going to be right
in our faces for the next few months you
know that Boris Johnson is going to be
called up in front of this committee
it's going to be televised and we are
going to publicly brand him a liar for a
second time and he could be ousted by
Christmas I don't think the country is
stable enough to have someone like Boris
Johnson in place Rishi who's not marred
by those accusations perhaps it's a
safer bet well he was fine and actually
that committee which is not set its
times of reference I'm sure very soon
we'll expand those terms of weapons to
scooping Rishi as well because as I said
he was in the same building breathing
the same air was also foreign
yes or no are you as a Tory MP stilatory
MP going to now back vichyssunaka's MP
and support him
um he's the leader of my party as prime
minister of the country of course okay
brilliant next tonight more from our
panel and a Dean's thoughts on the
gleeful BBC presenter being taken off
air after a reaction to Boris Johnson
pulling out of the top story leadership
race we're back in three
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
with me Emily Sheffield and Nadine Doris
still Weathers in the studio Quentin
let's Ava Santina and Kevin McGuire but
first let's cross the talk TV political
editor Kate McCann
Kate We Now understand Rishi will become
Prime Minister after meeting King
Charles tomorrow morning
yes that's right he will tomorrow is
going to be quite a morning because Liz
truss will chair her a final cabinet in
the morning where we expect her most
senior ministers will want to give her
perhaps a present maybe even a card to
say thank you it's been a very short
time in office but it is traditional for
that to happen and after that around 10
15 we expect that the Prime Minister
current Liz truss will give a speech in
Downing Street after that at around half
past 11 Rishi sunak will be the one
standing in front of the lectern and
giving his speech setting out exactly
what he intends to do during his time in
Downing Street and that will be Nadine a
really crucial moment because we've
heard from Rishi sinak already over the
last couple of hours he did a speech
from conservative party headquarters but
I think it's fair to say that some
people have been disappointed by the
tone of that speech and what they want
to hear from him is what he intends to
do for the country what he's going to do
during his time in office and exactly
what his priorities are because remember
we haven't really heard that debate
during this leadership ship contest we
know where he stands economically but we
also know he has a huge Challenge and a
lot of conservative MPS watching to see
what his next move will be so for him
that really will be a defining moment I
think tomorrow morning
so Kate the party is divided at the
moment do you think that rishi's got
enough time over two years to bring us
back together to unite and to win the
next general election
okay
it's very weird for both of us look I
think the mood in Westminster today is
generally relief even for those who
backed a different candidate during this
election they feel that at least
something has been put to bed but I
think that will be temporary because as
I was just saying there the economic
challenges that face Rishi sunak during
his time in office and particularly that
moment on Monday on Halloween when we
hear that medium-term fiscal plan that
will really Define the tone I think for
him the big question Nadine is how he's
going to bring a cabinet together that
as he says will contain all of the
talents that will mean moving some
people out and moving others in will he
do enough to unite the party and to give
people the feeling that he really is
listening to every wing of the
conservative party in Westminster but I
actually think the bigger question and
Nadine tell me if you think I'm right
here is about the membership because I
do believe that there is this growing
Gulf between the MPS in Westminster and
the membership of the conservative party
in the country and I think tonight there
will be many members who feel frustrated
at the way this process has happened
they may in time get behind wish you
soon Act 2 if it looks like he could win
the party in election but but you tell
me I mean I feel like they some of them
at least feel quite frustrated by how
this process has played out yeah and
you're absolutely right there are a
number of Facebook groups and various uh
social media groups as well as emails
coming in to MPS from members I think
one of them's got 45 000 members on who
are very very angry that they've been
disenfranchised I mean what is the point
of them being members of the political
party if they have no say who's going to
be the leader of the party and the Prime
Minister moving forward so so you're
absolutely right I have heard that it's
going to be
um Richie sunac's first public
appearance both to members answer is
going to be pmqs on Wednesday so we'll
all be able to to judge how he's going
to do then thanks so much Kate
thank you joining us now from
Westminster conservative MP and former
cabinet minister George Eustis now now
George just for some of our viewers
you've served on to Cameron you've
served under Theresa May you served
under uh Boris Johnson
um you uh served as an MP with his trust
but she did in fact sack you from your
job given the Psycho Drama we've all had
to um endure what makes you think Rashid
sunak um Can succeed we're going through
record numbers of prime ministers
well we are and I know to many of your
you know listeners and viewers that'll
seem quite extraordinary that the
conservative party put in place a new
leader and a prime minister you know
just a few weeks ago and it hasn't
worked out you know the truth is Liz
trust made you know some quite bold
moves but moves that in the end were
very risky and those risks came home to
ruse and it was very hard for her to
regain her footing after that and you
know after a number of other missteps
you know the party lost confidence in
her quite quickly and under our
constitution Prime Ministers they're not
it's not a presidential system no
individual prime minister has a mandate
as some people uh talk of it we have a
parliamentary democracy and
um Prime Ministers only exist while they
have the confidence of parliament in
general and their own parliamentary
party in particular and she didn't have
that so I know it's remarkable but it's
necessary for us to go through this and
I actually think that Richie sunac has
got you know the judgment and the
temperaments and the ability to to deal
with complex issues and detail to be
able to Rally the party behind him and
make the kind of right decisions we need
to to get through these difficult times
you were a Rishi sunak supporter over
the summer I actually saw you during
that that period And I I think he
definitely has the economic capabilities
to run run the country at the moment but
his speech today a lot of questions sort
of remain whether he's got the sort of
political Savvy I suppose to deal with
this job and and also the communication
skills we saw a speech today that was
almost a bit of a car crash it was
robotic there was a sort of ghastly
pause at the end Liz trust was a
terrible Communicator is he going to be
any better at communicating what fee
feels is right taking is up to not only
having to put in some really fairly
horrendous cuts at the moment and having
to explain that to a fairly doubtful
Nation but also get us through a general
election
oh I think he he is a good communicator
and you know I saw him in all of those
hustings over the summer and there was
something in him that actually reminded
me a bit about David Cameron now I've
worked for three different Prime
Ministers they each had different
strengths and different weaknesses but
you know the thing about David Cameron
is when he went on to do an interview or
do a speech you never feared for him you
didn't think he was going to sort of
mess it up or say something uh silly and
it generally didn't if he was asked
something left field or unpredictable he
could manage it and I see that in Rishi
as well and sadly we haven't really had
that in some of the other Prime
Ministers and party leaders we've had in
recent years Rishi performed incredibly
well I think in all of the hustlings
over the summer the party had that
debate and as for today look it's not a
a day when he can announce everything
he's going to do obviously he's made
clear he wants Cabinet Government he
wants to get a cabinet in place use that
cabinet properly deliberate over things
properly and make decisions correctly
and you know he has to be prime minister
first and that will happen now tomorrow
then he has to appoint his cabinet and
then he has to get cabinet buy-in for
the kind of measures he wants to take
forward and that's exactly the right
thing to do are you hoping for your old
job back
well I think he's very clear to be
honest that he's going to have to
balance all wings of the party and um
you know I had a reasonably good Innings
I did nine years in death for under
three different Prime Ministers would I
like to go back into government if asked
yes of course I would but you know all
prime ministers have got a very
difficult Balancing Act they need to
make sure that their cabinet represents
all wings of the party and there's an
important reason for that if you just
pack your cabinet with people who are
loyal and supportive to you then you
don't have people who understand your
parliamentary party so the reasons must
be brought what do you say to ladies
sorry what what what do you say to
neighbors charge we need a general
election
I don't accept that uh we don't have a
presidential system Boris Johnson didn't
get the Mandate in 2019 it was as much
about the message as the man and the
message that won the conservatives the
last general election was get brexit
done uh Rishi sunak was a brexiteer he
campaigned for brexit he was part of the
cabinet that got brexit done alongside
Boris Johnson and there's lots of other
things in that 2019 Manifesto that's our
mandate it's what all of us are elected
to do and that's what we should deliver
George thank you so much for joining us
tonight A BBC presenter has been taken
off air off she admitted to being
gleeful over news that Boris Johnson had
pulled out of the leadership race let's
take a look
well this is all very exciting isn't it
hello and welcome to our look ahead to
what the papers will be bringing us
tomorrow I'm allowed to be this gleeful
well I am then what do we do after that
Nadine what do you make of this you you
tweeted about this earlier
so in my previous Royal I was culture
secretary and um the BBC has a problem
with impartiality one they recognize
because they've introduced a 10-point
plan to deal with the lack of
impartiality I thought it was actually
shocking because you know people
perceive the bias in the BBC to be
amongst political reporters and
political presenters but this is
somebody who wasn't even in the
political
um grouping of people you'd normally
expect people to off air which is the
right thing to do so it's just um it's a
problem you know and it will it will be
a problem
um Tim Davey who's the Irish jungle the
BBC is something he's trying to Grapple
with every single day I would have
thought something would have been pretty
horrified he would have been absolutely
and it does seem extraordinarily uh
unprofessional Quentin what what what
was what was I'm a right-wing
sketchwriter and uh it's not really for
me to tick off other journals for
showing bias but if you are a presenter
it becomes tricky It's Tricky for the
BBC I feel a bit sorry for the woman but
um I don't think it's really my
thing to tick off others about that we
had the Sirota review the Dyson review
we've now got the impartiality plan from
the BBC there is a fundamental problem
within the BBC and they need to deal
with it we're acting like there's some
sort of like corruption or a virus in
that I mean it's just a woman who
laughed a little bit too loud and
frankly if it's anything it's
embarrassing but like too loud well the
comments that she was but she didn't
make the decision for Boris Johnson not
to run she had nothing to do with the
political sway but you know yeah
the director General Tim Davy the BBC
was a Tory Council candidate the chair
of the BBC used to work for Rishi sunak
and Satori Dorner I've lost count of the
number of BBC political journalists who
went to work for the concert was in in
government including uh
may I just say somebody who is on the
left it is not a hotbed of socialists to
laughs I wish it was
she's going to be giving her leaving
speech tomorrow she can't sum up like
other prime ministers have oh my years
she can say well I can sum up my 44 days
crashing the economy what's she even
gonna say tomorrow
well I don't think we are going to give
me sorry she's going to call for Unity
that's what she'll do because that's
what we need right now do you think
who's Unity
the party
the only unit is one you all hate each
other and two none of you on a general
election well it's exactly the same
they want a general election
well they do all hate each other
coming up next we turn our attention to
Ukraine is Putin about to unleash a
major escalation we're live in Kiev with
the latest
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back next tonight is Vladimir
Putin preparing to use a dirty bomb on
Ukraine president zielinski said Russia
could be planning an attack after weeks
of airstrikes left millions of
ukrainians without power
Russia's defense minister rejected the
claims and said Kiev had its own dirty
bomb
joining us now is Olga radenco editor of
the English-speaking Ukrainian newspaper
the Kiev independent Olga I saw you in
the summer in London
what's life like in Kiev now
hi Emily uh good to see you again and
thank you for having me well it's been a
channel a lot of anxiety for us in here
now because as you you mentioned the
dirty bomb threat that is the the newest
of the uh of several major excavation
threats that Russia has been throwing at
Ukraine in just under a week there are
there have been three major escalation
threats and one is a dirty bomb before
that we were talking about Russia's
threats to blow up a major uh Dam in
southern Ukraine that holds off a huge
water reservoir and Bone up to them
which fraud a huge chunk of land and and
uh potential kill lots of people and
before that we were talking about a
potential new Invasion from thelar who
is from North which would try to keep so
it's once right after another and this
can return the dirty bomb threat the
latest one is is probably the scariest
this one and at the same time at the
same time Russia has been doing this
um exertion strategy because as you said
there have been weeks of attacks on
Ukraine's energy facilities and as you
said Ukraine is a lot of us are left
without power I'm lucky to have power in
my apartment tonight but that means that
probably
um I will not have it in the morning
because there's a schedule of outages
and that's that's our life now and how
often are you losing power and also when
I was messaging you you've been in and
out of bunkers and and the Drone attacks
I mean what kind of effect has this had
on on on on on how people are feeling on
a day-to-day basis
I think you know just talking to
everybody around me everybody feels
um a lot of exhaustion because I think
uh just watching it on the news from
outside of Ukraine you can't really
um understand how it is draining on your
on your nerves
um and on your mental health just you
know living in this in this constant
fear especially in the past several
weeks when Russia has intensified
attacks and exactly one week ago five
people were killed in key when uh one of
those drones hit a residential building
and um uh yes I was in another shelters
I believe including us yes
she was six months pregnant she has her
husband and she and three other people
in their building were killed in that
attack and um you know a civilian uh
five-story building in central cave
um not any nothing in military Insight
um so but that's what Russia is doing
now and and yes we've been having daily
Aerials but taking them very seriously
now that's why
um when we're talking earlier today I
was in and out of a shelter and
how how do you think Ukraine can can win
this win this war Olga I mean you and I
have been in touch for many many months
now we're still here we're uh you and I
are very much of the opinion that you
know Ukraine it can't be ordered from
elsewhere from from Europe or America
that Ukraine does a deal with Russia but
how do you see this ending then
yes absolutely not
um I think even those who have been
thinking in the west that Ukraine could
be pushed into some kind of a deal with
Russia into a compromise sacrificing
lands I think
um that view is
um you know um less and less prevalent
because
I mean just being here and talking to
people and seeing the sheer resilience
and the sheer
um you know
the the way people feel about rationale
and how every time an attack on this
happens every time
um you know a civilian family is killed
in a brutal attack on like pregnant City
that adds to to the resilience and to
you know being ready to fight to the end
and I think you know um I'm not an
analyst but
I I firmly believe that the only way uh
to end this is a complete defeat of
Russia and it has to start with a
military defeat and that's why of course
we need for our Western parties
including the UK to keep supporting us
okay Olga thank you so much
um for coming on the show tonight in
such difficult circumstances thank you
Olga please stay safe
thank you
also where this is Ukrainian culture Mr
Alexander chenko how much longer should
the West keep sporting Ukraine Alexander
it's fantastic to see you again the
first time we met were the dark early
days of the war and you were sat in a
bunker trying to protect works of War
which was stacked around you how is it
now and how is life in Ukraine right now
for you
uh uh we're fighting and I can agree
with my colleague from give Independence
that the only way how we can succeed
this war is when Russia will withdraw
their troops from Ukraine so uh
according to uh latest opinion rules
from 80 to 90 percent of Ukrainian
citizens agree with president zielinski
that there is no question about any sort
of agreement arrangement with Russia
until they uh will do it
uh and if we speak up and if we speak
about latest attacks uh the main
reflection of ukrainians is
raising of their anger uh against what
Russians are doing uh against civilians
and civilians objects
so Alexander in the summer things seem
to get a bit easier in case
are you back in a more difficult
situation now than you were then is it
getting worse
I believe that at the beginning it was
uh the main reflection was
uh a sort of uh probably
we didn't know what to do but now we
definitely know what to do uh it's a
fight against Russians and a fight for
European values uh indifference Affairs
not only on the battlefield but also in
cultural sphere in a sphere of uh
fighting against propaganda and
information many things that we were
talking
so Alexander thank you for that you know
our hearts are with you and I hope we
speak again soon
Nadine
you work with Boris
he was incredibly involved
um with the war in Ukraine supporting um
Ukraine
uh lead us through where that where that
support came from because he he he he he
did in fact really he really did leave
lead no he did and you know there were
many big calls that Boris got right and
you know you've mentioned we've
mentioned some of them earlier but
Ukraine the advice virus was given by
manned Whitehall mandarins and everyone
was do not get involved but he was the
fight he took what was a very difficult
decision to be the first Western Country
to provide lethal Aid to Ukraine and to
arm Ukraine and to train Ukraine's
soldiers and I truly believe and many
truly believe in Ben Wallace the reason
why he supports Boris as much as he does
is because Barry stood up for Ukraine
when everyone else in the rest of the
world was saying don't it's too soon
it's too early and I truly believe that
if Bryce didn't do what he did Ukraine
would now be annexed by Russia and Putin
it was that early help that they got
from the UK despite the advice ice
despite the pressure on Boris not to do
it it was that early help they got which
has helped Alexander to be able to can I
just ask you one quick question do you
think if Rishi sunak offered Boris in
the next few months a sort of Ukraine
Envoy job would he take it because he is
passionate about it and he is a very
good communicator on that topic and he's
you know he's an expert you know Biden
said to him in their first call in their
first
um G7 call about Ukraine over to you bud
you know you lead the conversation
without to his knowledge he has
incredible knowledge of not just the
region but with the world affairs would
he take it if he was offered a role do
you think he would take I haven't asked
him but you know I will ask him that
question because I don't know I've I
he's got a lot to do a huge amount of
offers coming in at the moment so I'm
not sure
next tonight is nothing sacred is it
right to plan British tragedy into a
glossy entertainment well we'll be
discussing season five of the crown next
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
series of the crown has come under
intense criticism due to its portrayal
of the royal family Jane Judy Dench has
called for a disclaimer to be added to
the show for the sake of a family and a
nation so recently bereaved and former
prime minister John Major has dismissed
the series as a barrel load of malicious
nonsense
in light of the events of the last 12
months
I have more to reflect on than most
Health Royal scandals damaged the
country's reputation
I won't go quietly how about until the
end
still Weathers in the studio is the
times political sketchwriter Quentin
Letts and a warm welcome to historical
novelist I'm a fan girl Philippa Gregory
Quinton do you think it's a bit soon
after the death of her majesty for
Netflix to be screening something as
sensitive as this uh basically Nadine
I'm a Live and Let Live person and I
also dislike any sort of constraint on
freedom of speech but that shouldn't
stop us saying that
um this is the behavior of uh malicious
scavengers uh and that Netflix or at
least the the crown people are behaving
like
um like vultures but they are we should
see them not as vultures perhaps we
should see them as as ticks or fleas on
the hide of a magnificent the bathroom a
great Sleek bear that is the royal
family or is that it is monarchy and so
you know they're they're a small uh TV
outfit who watches Netflix and um uh I
think you know just let them have their
bit of uh my their little minor a bit of
uh drama and it is a drama it is a drama
yeah but what about the boys no Prince
William's side well that's where today
was the hardest day of his life this is
where you get into what a former um
there's a man called lord McGregor who
was in charge of press complaints and he
talked once about dabbling in people's
souls and this is where you get into
slightly difficult Waters because yes
this is a fiction and you know fiction
has uh a very important part to play in
our lives and in our art and our culture
but at the same time it's fiction based
on drama and it's so recent that that's
where you start trading into these
slightly sort of what about disclaimer
Quentin you know this England with
Kenneth Branagh had a disclaimer on the
front that said at the beginning of
every episode this is fiction well does
that I mean to put it on the trail and
on the actual program on the episode do
you know why would they put it on the
trailer why wouldn't they put it on the
episodes that air well I think you
probably have to be a bit stupid if you
don't understand the crown is pissed
well do you think it's a documentary I
don't know perhaps they should also have
a disclaimer saying that we you know we
Netflix employ Prince Harry so how could
he possibly be upset about this uh you
know
actually employ him do they well they
give him loot well he's made they're
making a document quite a lot he's not
actually employing them but do you not
thinks are involved in the making of
that program but there is there is a
build up of pressure for Netflix to put
disclaimer on the front do you think
they should bow to that pressure will
they bow to pressure first from Sir John
Major I think they might possibly might
ignore him
um and they have they have put it on the
trailer already so we could see we could
see movements I think I think this is a
this is a hoo-ha and we enjoy getting
upset about it and it is a bit unseemly
it's unsporting it's unkind but it's
it's
apart I've read all your novels so um
what do you think you fits wrong that
the royal family don't I mean you write
about an amazing not about Elizabeth at
first but this the royal family today
they don't have a right of reply it's
not a historical documentary it's very
much involving members of the royal
family you're alive today do you think
it's wrong that they don't have the
right to reply of course they have the
right to reply they just have to speak
up nobody's stopping them speaking out
when they want to speak out they do and
they want to sue people they do they
have every right to reply but this isn't
a factual account that they can sue for
libel over though I would imagine that
depending on how close Netflix gets the
win there might be things that would
look up up but nobody thinks it's real I
mean if you show me one person who
thinks this is history then we'll have a
completely different discussion because
what we're doing a lot of people we're
setting I think this is how a lot of
people do you know royal family and I
think that's a credit to the writers
Well everybody's actually explaining
about the fact that it doesn't carry a
disclaimer
phone the people are complaining about
the fact that it doesn't have a
disclaimer are the people who don't want
the story told and the way that the
journalists at the dramatists are
telling it it's not that they're
complaining that it's about real people
it's that they're complaining that they
think other people not their intelligent
literate well-read selves are getting
the wrong end of the stick and this is
just the usual thing about stupid people
out there are doing stupid things and I
should set them right so Philippa is it
close to the Bone do you think it's
closer to the truth than perhaps those
who people who are complaining don't
realize well since the Freedom of
Information Act doesn't cover the Royal
palaces there's no historian that can
check it out the fact checking that's
been in private lives how can it be
checked out because they're monarchs
because they're Royal because they dive
at people their individuals have a right
to privacy and to not have their private
lives televised or made into factional
documentaries which they are very far
from the truth nobody has that right
I know we all have that right but can we
really argue that about them I mean no
we're talking about some of the most
famous people about the famous people in
the world and what we're arguing now is
whether it is a painful thing for the
two brothers who lost who lost their
mother but that is 25 years they don't
have to watch it if they don't want you
have edited a big newspaper and you know
that there are it's not necessarily
written down in law sometimes what what
one can write about it's to do with uh
what where the acceptable bands are on
the sport of it and Netflix do they
trade in they trade in a slightly dodgy
way on this and they try to do present
this by making it so such a facsimile of
and making the characters so life-like
making them all sound like the real
members of the royal family they are
trading on on slightly half truths there
and the real truth in this the truth the
truth is not to do who said what when
and where it's to do with uh aspects of
character and I think that the great
truths in life are based on character
and we know what the character of the
queen was we know what the character of
King Charles is and I think that the
public will see through that and the the
audiences will establish a truth of
their own I mean I I I'm my actual
personal opinion is the crown has done a
normal good for the royal family and
including King Charles actually because
I think the portrayal of him as a young
man was very sympathetic and we saw
elements of him that maybe made us think
when he feels a bit wooden or when we
saw him at his accession there was a
moment when he got a little bit angry
and a bit testy that there's that that
childhood scene when he sent off to
Gordon Stern and his mother turning away
from him I think it made us realize what
some of the sort of pressure of growing
up in that in that family was so maybe
the argument is the royal family can't
can't have it both that's good for the
Royal firm in in America Quentin
Philippa thank you so much two sports
have just stopped oil have covered
Madame two swords wax work model of King
Charles III with chocolate cake today
the climate activists are demanding the
government halts all new oil and gas
licenses and consents Nadine what do you
make of this well the tarquins and the
others were in central Lobby in
Westminster today up to similar antics
you know it's it's an Indulgence you
know we've been staying for a long time
we have to stop this they disrupt
everybody's lives they stop ambulances
getting to hospitals they stop people
getting to work they stop children
getting to school they they deface
statues and and monuments they just have
to stop it's totally unacceptable
oh well cop 26 was the most successful
conference there has been held ever in
the United States
and are you continuing with the cop 26
resolution yes
by Madame two swords they've always had
a brilliant PR effort
now they are dressed up as Justin I I
think I I'm not
waiting on the program tomorrow so
they'll be able to come and defend their
actions to us directly and to you that's
it from us but we'll be back again
tomorrow at 8pm
whatever you're up to make sure it's
uncensored good night and good night
from me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]